une production du studio sfb venu au
sans filtre le podcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut nous inviter bâtisse est
super content avec moi de dôme plantes
habituellement pas aujourd'hui domine
encore à québec
mais ne vous inquiétez pas il va revenir
bientôt cette semaine le sans fil très
présenté par un vive smoothie un vif
soutien en fait cédé smoothie qui
viennent congelé dans un petit club
comme ce tout ce que vous avez à faire
c'est de pop et les petits clubs dans la
liquid de votre choix
mais je le mets dans l'eau peut le
mettre dans des boissons végétales peut
mettre dans du lait on chez quelques
dizaines de secondes et vous avez un
smoothie prêts à boire
c'est une compagnie que je connaissais
déjà que j'utilisais déjà en fait je
consommais déjà reproduit pour plusieurs
raisons notamment parce que comme je
viens de vous l'expliquer c'est super 5
mais aussi parce que c'est 100%
végétales y est et billons ayons des
smoothies aux fruits on est motivé on
discute ici plus protéines et encore une
fois que des protéines 100% végétale
donc c'est vraiment de la boxe une
compagnie québécoise ça a été fondé par
un couple d'entrepreneurs d'ici
puis nous auto sans fil consultant un
plaisir de collaborer avec des
entreprises québécoises
donc je vous recommande fortement
d'aller sur leur site web tchèques et
leurs produits je vais mettre le lien
dans la déception ne s'est pas cassé
mais aussi d' activement cherché leurs
produits en épicerie en fait vous allez
dans les congélateurs ils ont un beau
petit sac vous allez le voir tout de
suite c'est vraiment très short puis vie
vous conseille d'essayer ce rapidement
sinon le sans filtre est également
présentée aujourd'hui par planet roster
planethoster c'est une société
d'hébergement web pour la collaboration
nous on ne me grey notre site 20h
planethoster ces deux hommes s'est
occupé de tout
mais ça a été super simple grâce au
soutien technique en fait deux
m'écrivait un email avec le conte sans
fil fait que je les voyais passer aussi
puis aux stocks écrivent un email il se
faisait renvoyer tout de suite une
marche à suivre qui avaient des
questions c'est vraiment prendre par la
main pour faire le changement de
de domaine est en fait plein entre
autres s'engagent à vous donner
gratuitement l'équivalent du reste de la
balance des mois que vous aviez avec
votre fournisseur préalable donc par
exemple si vous avez un contrat de 12
mois qui après quatre mots voulait faire
attention vers planethoster il vous a
fait 8 mois gratuitement
c'est pour des particuliers qui veulent
faire un blog ce pour des grosses
compagnies qui veulent avoir un site web
super complexe tout et tout le spectre
en fait don à l'autre en passant par un
pme comme le studio sf on est très
heureux d'avoir fait affaire avec eux si
vous avez un obnl
ils vous offrent 25 % et d'organismes à
but non lucratif 25% pour vous aider et
sinon on a nous un code promo c'est le
ph a trait d'union sans trait d'union
filtre on va mettre sur toute façon
toutes les informations dans la
description du podcast donc si vous avez
voulu un site web vous savez où aller
merci à plaindre autres merci arrivisme
outils de rendre le podcast possible
sinon cette semaine on a reçu rosalie
bon enfant une animatrice une actrice
une autre hills ça fait beaucoup
est ce une créatrice de contenus une
influence or et une jeune femme aux
multiples chapeaux mais elle est porte
tous très bien en fait on a parlé là
derrière websérie de rose elle est
animée s'appelait c'est quoi le trip
surtout pour intégrer ou est-ce qu'à
s'intéresser à des tendances actuelles
comme le véganisme le minimalisme
les femmes qui se laissent pousser le
poil et on a parlé de ce beaucoup mais
rapidement ces tombes un peu plus dans
le dip dans la recherche la croissance
personnelle est tous vraiment comme
plusieurs de nos invités au podcast
quelqu'un qui fait pas son âge du tout
on dirai clairement que c'est pas son
premier tour de piste sur la planète
terre donc une conversation passionnante
qu'ont eue j'espère que vous allez
l'aimer autant qu'ils nous ont aimé la
voir
sinon en fait si vous voulez participer
à la discussion commenté que ce soit sur
balles à dos ou spotify où que ce soit
sur youtube participer aux conversations
on ne répond pas tous les les les
commentaires pardon mais on les lit tous
donc commenter ça nous fait toujours
plaisir de voir votre point de vue sinon
les signaux et europe 1 racing
vous savez comment ça marche a fait son
bout de chemin et dans le fond via notre
page pétulant aussi si vous venez
encourager avoir accès à du contenu
exclusif
tout ça c'est dans la destruction vous
connaissez le tralala
sans plus attendre je vous laisse avec
cette magnifique conversation avec
rosalie bonne enfin bon podcast
[Musique]
ps merci rosalie d'être là merci à vous
je pense que je me suis un peu à éviter
en plus
ouais ça fait ça fait longtemps
je pense que tu m'avais créé apprennent
que l'ol le packaging et loyettes m'a
dit je prends mon numéro bleu chez kiwi
gauche ne revient que j'étais comme
jamais revenue parce que après sur nous
on a déménagé on avait déjà le plan de
l'agent le studio plomb les deux comme à
bouquet comme quasiment dernière minute
non non sauf que la presse ont regardé
akela comme explosion à les invités qui
ont invité petits ressorti que je suis
retourné voir dix ans il serait je vois
d'écrire un billet le chah d'iran et dms
après c'est vrai j'avais écrit ce afin
que parfait mais j'étais trop contente
je me disais je trouve que je fais pas
cette podcast c'est mon avis c'est un
premier pas qui c'est on maudit je sois
parler en plus quelque chose que je me
reconnais dans des podcasts je pense
n'avoir vu un sur youtube n'ont donc à
savatan oui avec jpy qui était un des
recherchés sur sucrés salés
ok mais vous êtes mon premier c'est que
le produit comme la grande grande pièce
s'appelle enfants non par tous frais qpc
malade moi et m'a pas vraiment la
question j'ai pour toi aucun à voir avec
ça c'est comme une fois par jour si
c'est parler de dire on fait du
personnage et pétroliers la première
fois aujourd'hui c'est assez bon bah
ouais ok pas que c'est vraiment pas
pires que ceux c'est vraiment plus au
travail que je le sentais commence à
côtoyer bédéthèque urbain des gens comme
toi y ait pas que c'est plus du et
comment tavaux mélanie ce jeu les pas
mal mais tant mieux comme tels potins et
relier en direct personne doit aborder
ces nouvelles mais le monde va avoir des
nouvelles de dans une galaxie maintenant
qu'on me demande qui travaillent à tizi
ouzou
personnage vient ça gèle les potes
acteurs casse a joué tu es trop jeune ou
d'écouter ceux achetés min j'avais
minimes 2 ans qui tenait tête un peu
plus vieille que ce j'ai des photos de
moi comme 4-5-1 mettons sur le plateau
mais je t'aime eenie meenie de vue le
plateau de thé x d'auto suisse et
l'allemagne ces malades
ouais c'est moi ça a marqué cette
émission ça a marqué ma jeunesse
toi aussi tout à fait on a 28
vous avez plus est à l'écouté c'est une
émission qui marqua sur radio enfer qui
du bio non mes émissions québécoises moi
c'est pas mal d'occasions en faire je
pense qu'ils que je me souviens qu'ils
mettront les midis à des mimes l'espace
qui mixe rares extraits cap et demi cet
ennemi moi j'ai joué dans les studios à
radio canada quand ma mère allait
retourner
il y avait les stellistes l'éducation
qui est ennemie tacle moi je jouais à la
vétérinaire mais j'ai quatre nuits ça me
dit rien pantoute
ces malades d'arrêter quand tu grandis
dans un dans un milieu comme ça pète est
exposée tient à des plateaux le les ans
ils se dotent créé laitiers dans juste
le meetic d'aujourd'hui je lis avec moi
la fête la capsule ensemble sur le
véganisme et sa fille mais pas pendant
mais qui sait ça on arrive le plus tôt
et où tu dis tu me diras et ça va
vraiment pas le genre je pense que tu
vomis celle matin c'était la grosse
grosse migraine ophtalmique pas quelques
heures avant que tu arrives genre je
voyais plus je parlais plus je peux plus
me suis même pas que je mettais mon dieu
il sent bien c'est la première fois
qu'on sera riche et complète de l'isf
est une hérésie quand même là je
m'excuse c'est utile à tulle a adressé
lundi je m'excuse là aujourd'hui je vais
vraiment pas bien mais comme on va
essayer de faire ce qu'il faut faire
ça m'a traité forking sacoche pendant
l'entrevue comme tel c'est pendant la
capture puis n'importe qui écoutent
cette capsule a aucune idée mais ça
c'est espèce de j'aimerais remercier
suzanne morales une excellente
maquilleuse next
c'est celle que les cars et les tâches
étage de vomir ils laissèrent non ça tu
vois j'ai appris à briser écrit temps
avec l'expérience
mais est ce que est ce que comme d'être
exposé jeunes a souhaité créer une
espèce d'aisance dans ton métier ou
sagesse aucun rapport tue le jeu est
développé par la pratique
non ça définitivement créé en fait c'est
que ça annulé l'effet comme
impressionnant des plateaux sont
annulées
oh mon dieu c'est comme s'il y avait un
petit prêt supplémentaire c'est déjà
stressant de donner des entrevues de
jouer devant les autres mais pour moi
c'est comme tuer cela dans l'oeuf et il
n'y avait pas de vélo aujourd'hui je me
rends sur un plateau c'est très sérieux
pour moi c'était juste comme il ya ça
sent bon les éclairages mon préchauffé
j'adore tes j'adore l'ambiance mais
c'est surtout que ça enlevé l'espèce
d'aspe comme anticipé laissé intimider
ou même de glorification la notoriété
était pour moi est reconnu c'est juste
quelque chose qui fait que ta marque le
pas venir à ronde avec toi comprend
quelque chose que j'ai cherché à
atteindre dans ma vie ou que je cherche
à temps une présentement c'est plus à
tous à jouer ça normalise un petit peu
ce métier là qui est tellement tellement
flou pour les gens qui connaissent
poitiers comme qui apparaît comme maman
sur un piédestal à porte pour nécessaire
cette expérience c'est plus ce que j'ai
jamais compris parce que j'ai connu rien
d'autre
mon père fait un autre métier mais ma
mère ça a toujours été ça se passe comme
si à 40 ans est venue les gotti je me
lance dans ce milieu le fac pour moi ça
a plu c'était un mais voyons mes amis
peuvent voir venir jean louis y avoit
bas et marrante viennent chez nous tout
j'ai donc parlé c'est correct mais non
c'est ça a vraiment et ça a vraiment
juste enlever le côté glam
ouais ce qui ce qui doit te permettre
d'arriver taratata faire le petit de
gérer ça comme comme n'importe quel job
en font pas n'importe quel job pas cité
cette semaine met dans des situations
auxquelles la plupart des chansons pas
confrontés ne serait-ce que la fidélité
et et quand tu dois jouer quand tu dois
avoir la proximité physique avec
quelqu'un d'autre
c'est pas tous les couples qui sont
confrontés à ça mais en même temps ça
reste quand même juste une job mais ça
reste quand même quelque chose pourquoi
on reçoit des sous c'est moi je te
échanges de services comme n'importe
quel autre travail finalement on se met
tellement beaucoup de ton
l'investissement émotionnel personnel à
d'antiques et c'est une job je pense que
tu as besoin d'être parvenir à ben je
peux sud de la corse que je dis qu'il a
besoin de montrer que c'est tellement
impliquant c'est ce que j'ai je sais pas
si on a besoin d'être vulnérable moi je
suis rien d'autre que vulnérable aux
anges
j'ai pas encore trouvé le chemin pour
offrir autre chose que la fragilité mais
en mettant ce moment où il en manque un
peu c'était demande de contenu qui ont
neuf tellement de contenu qui est
travaillée qui est pensée éthique que ce
soit dans les médias traditionnels ou
sur le web
j'ai l'impression que tout est tellement
calculé que on a un peu besoin justement
de ce thé des podcasts ou le monde se
parle sans prétention à bâtons rompus
que c'est pas nécessairement une joute
oratoire où un peu pour faire et heurter
deux de ses connaissances ou quoi que ce
soit c'est vraiment juste pour se
présenter tel que tu es qui montrent que
c'est ce que je recherche
quand je consomme n'importe quel contenu
donc c'est ce que j'essaie de frais
aussi le temps city way même en plus ça
stoppe attrape les dix autres
personnages peut pas être appliquée aux
quais de vendôme puis pierre jetée de
même pas que leur avenir avec un plus de
même personnalité quand tu es juste toi
même c'est tellement facile
est ce que est ce que
c'est un sujet qu'on n'abordait pas
passer par un appel d'offres sous mais
allons-y
j'ai de plus en plus d'une heure avec
les réseaux sociaux qu'est ce que on
cultive tout le monde ensemble avec ce
j'ai de plus en plus de misère avec
ouais ça sans voter puis c est cette
idée là d'être authentique
j'ai l'impression qu'à deviennent de
plus en plus galvaudé absolue de dire
l'authenticité devient une espèce de
trine marque fait clair tout le monde
et oui c'est pas parce que le même temps
le nouveau centre nc de te qualifier du
filtre mettant hors jeu sur ça devient
jouer un jeu on dirait on dirait que se
plier aux règles parce que derek qui
fluctuent comme si elles étaient des
traîne sur les soupes de s'y plier on
dirait que même si la règle c'est soit
authentique
ça devient par définition plus
authentique moment de pause quelque
chose qu'une décision il y avait un
choix considéré comme moi je peux comme
je sais que c'est un peu sur mon
étiquette la fille vrai ça que j'étais
un peu dans un mode de jeu méthode le 3
je reviens de tourner et j'ai un
maquillage à ce que les gens vont se
dire voyons pourquoi cas se maquiller
les consciences intérêt naturel old au
large on me dit mais en même temps j'ai
l'impression que souvent on a tendance à
se présenter un peu en victime face aux
réseaux sociaux comme si on n'avait pas
le choix de consommer ce comme bon nous
semble
comme ça on n'avait pas le choix de ce
qui nous était offert tandis que moi
j'ai l'impression que le monde demande
ce qu'il veut c'est pas vrai que on se
dit oh le ce qui marche c'est de
présenter une telle photo plus fortement
dépassé les attentes à leur faire le
monde s'habitue à ce que tu lui donnes
je pense que quand on commence à en voir
tes plus de filles démaquiller plus de
filles très maquillée puis qui disent
regardez je suis très maquillée
y comme ça j'ai l'impression que ça va
finir par chez pas moi j'ai l'impression
qu'une espèce d'unicité qui va finir par
par sortir de ce parce qu'on a tous le
contrôle sur neuf puisqu'on consomme t
c'est pas vrai qu'il ya quelqu'un en
les jours de semaine à partir de
maintenant c'est les filtres plus blanc
qui pogne c'est juste parce que c'est ça
qu'on offre
si on n'embarque là-dedans pilon voir ça
comme ça qu'on le leur parce qu'on veut
pas négocié de la même façon que les
autres bugs mais quand tu comprends que
quand même payant être toi même qui
offrirent ta propre couleur que personne
peut imiter
ouais moi je trouve que c'est
rafraîchissant ben oui tout à fait je
les passions c'est ce qui va rester au
final j'ai beaucoup aimé ton maître
admettons qu'on se projette dans je peux
cinq ans puisqu'elle est une nouvelle
plateforme qui qui qui voit le jour
puisqu'elle est là d'une transition vers
ces plateformes lotz et puis l'histoire
l'histoire à ses raccourcis des réseaux
sociaux nous aura prouvé que c'était
tout le temps d émergence de nouveaux
médias qui arrive puis la note que ce ça
va arriver
j'ai l'impression que ces gens là qui
sont réellement eu même qui vont juste
continuer à avoir des gens qui vont être
attirés vers eux peu importe la
plateforme ces maisons instagram sur une
plate forme de photos avec les photos il
détourne de photos une façon d'aimer les
photos il ya un algorithme autour des
photos mais quand les photos sont
parties tout ce qui reste c'est la
personne c'est qu'est-ce qui reste
vraiment au final est ce que est ce
qu'ils disent est juste on ici tu et à
toi que l'ofac les gens vont continuer à
tuer si j'ai l'impression que rapidement
il voit un espèce de tricks va se faire
du moins je l'espère je l'espère parce
que je trouve s'est rangé à cette petite
heure peu puis j'aime pas beaucoup sur
moi je trouve qu'un problème ex cat voix
était sculptée à la juste pour ado oui
oui juste pour alonso on en parle quand
il s'agit de chercher mon gars mais ça
va me chercher parce que c'est comme on
dirait que j'ai vraiment un malaise
profond avec la façon que c'est comme
c'est fait j'ai un malaise profond avec
la façon que comme des clôtures du monde
jouit lui ce que j'ai écrit sur
l'événement non j'ai justement je pense
le lendemain j'ai juste donné mon
opinion qui était exactement ce qui est
pourquoi on ne tombaient les pressions
que c'est une finalité de défiler sur
cette maudite at il eu alors que dans le
fond c'est pas vrai que tu es plus vale
do plus important en vous ou même plus
style plus pertinent juste parce que tu
es sur ce tapis le mont s'il ya quelque
chose qui met mal à l'aise de me dire
mais c'est comme si tu dis
biz les vedettes de la clé si je
comprends que c'est pas sur les
intentions mais c'est ce que ça te sort
en même temps c'est littéralement
comminges où le désir d'être le droit de
me toucher mais j'espère dessus de la
barrière dit je comprends qu'il faut
contrôler la grande folie pain mais en
même temps moi je trouve que l'allée des
vedettes comme jeudi dans sexuelle est
un peu une allée pour se mesurer la
popularité
c'est un peu d'aller rechercher des like
dans vraie ville c'est l'approbation en
vraie vie mais c'est ceux qui évoquent
et que les gens par d'être le témoin
c'est de là qu'est née ma réflexion je
mettais pourquoi les gens remercie je
comprends pas pourquoi les gens
merci leurs fans oui je comprends pas
que vous faites pour moi pauvre est mais
je comprends pas pourquoi les gens c'est
d autant porté par une vague d'amour
puis merci grâce à vous je flotte sur un
nuage
moi c'est là que je trouve ça peut
toucher parce que je me dis si peu ta
job qui te fait vivre sur un nuage en
jeu s'est pas créé ce que tu paies c'est
petit c'est la gratification des gens
qui justifie que tu es en train de
forcer son talent face comme de dire hey
merci tellement pour vous sans
commentaires sur ma photo - tellement
chaude grâce à vous avant seul je me
sentais coupable mais maintenant ma vie
balit & gas mais c'est une chance vous
êtes là pour se les jambes pour
continuerait grâce à votre vague d'amour
si c'est les gens sont là pour échanger
avec nous pister du donnant donnant et
ses potes du donne en prenant toute
invalidation le ça va être quoi quand
qu'est le public va être moins
rendez-vous que tout dans un creux thème
année aussi forte validation
ça vient de l'intérieur il faut que ce
soit bien et toi moi un peu importe s'il
faut être capable de quelqu'un qui était
content négatif outre capable de prendre
cette des crises ce cas positifs ces
genres fuck off le puis je peux laisser
sa marraine mais si tu fais souffre
aussi que le trop positifs
c'est en fait avec ce qu'il faut aussi
que tu prennes surface ok c'est cool ou
steam et on y était 6e du monde c'est du
bon du négatif aussi du pertinente
négatif que tu le prennes visite vers
ceux du positif
mais encore faut-il s non plus
un côté comme de l'autre affecté comment
que toi tu sens avec toi même noté je
crois que c'est surtout que c'est le je
pense que ton contenu devient
conditionné par qu'est ce qui va moins
aussi 16 à licques de réaction c'est là
je pense que toute bête tendance qu'on
peut avoir tendance à s'éloigner un peu
de ce qu'on est pour plaire c'est seul
danger parce que c'est tellement facile
de placer les cotes sont tellement
claire moi-même googlé how to get likes
ils vont tes données les trucs le c'est
pas sorcier mais un moment donné ça te
dirai ce que je veux bâtir un auditoire
qui est le plus vaste possible ou qui me
ressemblent plus lui et qui peu importe
ce que je vais publier vos abonder un
peu dans mon sens ce qui va me suivre à
long terme t il ya [ __ ] tu sais déjà
qui vise la carrière de ce flou burn
notice à ce que c'est le fun la
gratification instantanée téléphone soit
par dire constamment quel point on et
off puis à quel point on est parfaite
jamais été aussi accessible hocine c'est
tellement accessible
c'est clair quant au fait la série
s'appelait c'est quoi le trépas c'était
sur tou.tv
puis il y avait plusieurs sujets y avait
comme une émission entre six et huit
capsules le cap sud merci je peux bouger
mon corps 5 packs avait eu huit capsules
c'était quoi les sujets d u est pas ce
que je veux je veux pas ce qu'il fait
mais ton bouquin de nous c'était le
véganisme notre notre capsule puis chez
que je suppose que je le fais pour vrai
mais c'était un espèce de une semaine
après aussi tu laisses ayez pour vrai
puis il y avait comme un peu de
d'essayer de toi te portes de prêter au
jeu et puis de participer à autre et
c'est ça le concept sont sertis comprend
des tendances actuelles qui on essaye de
comprendre d'où vient l'engouement vers
le véganisme vers la méditation verts se
déshabiller ses ressources et réseaux
sociaux donc on rencontrait des experts
des spécialistes ont presté jesse le ph
qui était notre expert puis après ça moi
je les tester pendant à départ le team
est on pour les poêles ça a été un test
d'un mois mouche vous loguez mon
expérience ça a été une semaine puis à
neutrons admettons qu'on passe les caps
qui veut ça me passionne bars et des
sujets qui sont tellement
l'actuel de tact vraiment puis mettons
qu'on passe les capsules bic ont enfin
espèce de résumer de s'arrêter quoi ton
expérience à travers c'est un tracé très
plus la première émission c'était quoi
c'était je sais du minimalisme annonce
test des as bien sûr les additionner les
tripes de se montrer il y avait à l'anis
qui étaient là tu dis qu il explique que
le spécialiste
quand un brainstorm pour ces sujets
lancé qu'il experte qu'ils ne pensaient
ils avaient trio qui ont ces métiers on
la voit partout il habite pis moi je
bosse est difficile de l'inviter parce
que c'est une entrepreneure à la
bastille jamais dit ça va être difficile
car nous parle de montrer ci fais pas ça
le dire le besoin de les montrer
maintenant mais ce qui est intéressant
avec alanis c'est qu'il y avait eu tes
toute la saga avec marilyn gens que tu
moi je me suis pour qu'on les hait soit
peu face à face puis on leur donne pas
l'occasion de s'expliquer philo c'était
cool off phone 7 sur le puits on en a
gardé étaient trois minutes parce que
c'est des épisodes de comme 15 mai on
était partis pendant quasiment une heure
lord a parlé c'était tellement un
échange intéressant c'est le te rends
compte que tout le monde est tellement
plus nuancé que ce qu'on pense oui tout
le temps tous les niveaux que ces
facilités de faire des crocs jam apidés
des gros article tellement chaud qu'un
sur les gars qui se passe en tout le
monde mais finalement tout le monde se
rejoint
atik nord métier l'internet encourage
aussi les opinions tranchées et pythie
destructrice et dont on n'a pas le temps
on au pôle luxe d'être si nuancé outils
qu'on lit on sur mac réactions que je te
manque un conte les -1 puis en plus les
articles y sont repris son temps que le
sont encore moins c'est fait que c'est
effectivement qui nous autres c'est une
expérience au podcast à chaque fois
qu'on reçoit quelqu'un on sera encore
défendre une idée aussi de préconçue de
quel genre d'opinion qui ces personnes à
voir quel genre de type de personne puis
finalement toujours toujours plus de
renseignements vous essayez de faire
pogner le faut' s'amorce
on aperçoit maintenant je pense que ça
allait jack catherine brunel c'est comme
une opinion gardien s'est tranché sur
les
florence heures puis il parlant pendant
une heure et demie t on se rend compte
que 95 % du chemin parcouru qui louis
torreilles ce qui est une première phase
de l'examen d'hadopi vraiment bien
entendu froment fait violer ses droits
sociaux le tout apprécié ce à quoi il
fallait qu'il fasse hors jeu enfin je me
suis déshabillé vous avez joué aussi une
photo en sous vêtements puis ça pour moi
c'était où ça a été le test le plus
éprouvant a dit guy subra way absolument
je tasser avec ta publie aussi une
fallait que je vois que notre
productrice christine un super ouverte
et est douce et dans le respect des facs
d'emblée avec ce concept on savait que
le but c'était que je repousse les
limites mais pas que je me fasse
violence non plus d amour est plus fort
c'est non non plus il ajoute en mai puis
sur le coup je n'ai pas publié
parce que je me disais je pense pas que
j'en ai besoin évidemment je m'en suis
servi pour re faire la promo du jour
j'ai lu publiées mais je les publie avec
comme avec ma photo de mes poils que si
ça a été éprouvant pour moi parce que
j'étais assez pudique c'est à dire que
tu es j'ai pas de problème a porté les
buteurs des délais tout mais j'ai jamais
ressenti vraiment la peine de montrer
mon corps sur les réseaux on dirait que
la satisfaction d'abord mon chemin qui
me le confirme mon effort
je me dis ok je gomme ces gouttes mais
sent bien où je me sens pas si bien
piste est correct puisque j'ai pas
besoin que ça regarde les autres mais
c'est ce qui est le fun avec ce projet
leur c'est que ça m'amène vraiment à
pousser ma réflexion il ya un petit
édito au début de chaque capsule où je
donne mon opinion façon un peu
humoristique qui justement mon point tel
que j'essaie pondre et que j'en ai pas
besoin
tu sais la presse que je me suis
réveillé je me dis pourquoi ça pourquoi
il faudrait que ça parte d'un besoin
c'est pourquoi chacune des photos que je
mais je me dis pas ça par d'un besoin de
me montrer mais ce il faudrait que ça il
faudrait que ça soit comme validé par un
texte ou quoi que ce soit je me suis dit
c'est vraiment peu si graves que ceux de
la peau finalement c'est pis je pense
que c'est en étant encouragés justement
par des gestes et des licences des faits
it et qui s'assume dans ce qu'elles sont
que je ne sais pas je pense pas que ça
va altérer la valeur le de publier cette
photo le savent bien le faire avec moi
qui le fais est-ce que c'est le site est
plus de réactions une réaction plus de
qu'est-ce que ça le fait
cette photo le pas tant parce que quand
même savamment cachés mais tu vois j'ai
fait des photos avec max gourgues cet
été ou jetés comme read que l'on voit un
seizième de voiture un trou encore de
côte qui 1 6 8e de side beau bleu pis ça
a été ma photo la plus aimée sur un
diagramme je les ai vus parce que on
attend les laïcs
à ce moment le dimanche mais je me
disais c'est tellement choquant parce
que je peut me forcer à écrire un texte
qui va voir une fraction la réaction que
info king size beau buzz suscité par
contre est que c'est juste pour ceux que
ça me choque c'est de savoir que montrer
que j'ai pas dis pas que c'est de la
facilité mais j'ai pas envie de tomber
là dedans 2 si je me connais le moment
si j'aime ceux de la gratification
instantanée et je me dis je vois qu
après c'est facile
j'aime mieux continuer à à me concentrer
sur ce que je fais est iap dansons sous
scellés pourquoi je le ferais pourquoi
je commencerai à mettre des photos c'est
parce que mettons je réfléchis l'oeil
puis je suis vraiment qu'apple traite
avec vous si je commence à le faire
alors que je n'ai jamais fait c'est
parce que les autres le font c'est parce
que je me dis ben les autres ont
l'opportunité de montrer leur corps
pierre quel point leur corps est beau
quand il y est déshabillé fac moi aussi
je voudrais montrer que vous trouvez que
ma phase 1b elle mais je veux que vous
trouviez que mon corps est beau side
j'ai pas envie d'avoir besoin de cette
piste est pas c'était pas
et c'était pas une intuition pour faire
ce à prime abord
non parce que je n'ai pas à l'aise de le
faire mais c'était vraiment dans
l'esprit de thé je me renseigne de plus
en plus bas de plus en plus mais dans
les dernières années j'ai commencé à me
renseigner beaucoup sur le féminisme qui
à redéfinir un peu d opinion que j'avais
depuis longtemps qui l'a en fait c'est
que j'ai décroché un rôle qui sent bien
dont j'ai pas encore le droit de parler
mais pour les pour lequel va voir des
scènes de nudité que ça me sam est
mortifiée ah ouais j'ai même failli
comme c'est difficile pour moi mais si
ça a été quand même un espèce de de wake
up call où je mettais le bateau alors
que j'apprenne à me dissocier un peu de
mon corps parce que c'est mon outil de
travail tu es si je veux être comédienne
dans vie j'ai besoin de pas trop penser
que chaque parcelle de chair
m'appartient mais ça m'appartient métier
c'est pas su se créer bon juste ce
qu'elle polichinelle et sa chair mais
tout le monde le sait la personne va
être complètement saisi
c'était le texte que safina n'est un
geyser ces décors qui sont pas là pour
être désiré qui sont pas là pour pour
nécessairement jugé qu'ils sont juste là
pour exister picone qui sont le messie
c'est que j'ai trouvé que son clip sexy
c'est zéro sexualisé été c'est juste
c'est juste un décor ou naturelle c'est
quelque chose de tellement abu justement
dans une nudité simple normal c'est
juste qu'ils existent comme se dit le
tient aux normes éthiques sommes tus est
en fait le tai chi et olé la sérénité
sur juste pour exister
pis si parfait puis dans toutes sortes
différentes magnifique fallu six boucles
c'est sur la mode puis a dit gilles
entendu à radio canada inc sont son clip
est sorti le pire était est encore forte
et à rimouski encore parce qu'ils
revenaient des îles de la madeleine
tu as dix mois après l'avoir fait comme
je fais
du monokini aux îles-de-la-madeleine ces
choses que j'ai réellement la deuxième
journée avec quelque chose qui soude
chez dans sa façon de percevoir son
corps c'est une déconstruction sont des
constructions à faire la sexualisation
du corps vraiment mais c'est aussi que
ces essais porté aussi par un double
standard c'est à dire que puis moi même
si je pense que la meilleure façon de
grandir c'est de se remettre constamment
en question puis moi même j'ai longtemps
été challenge et par la nudité des
autres pays parce que j'avais peur
mettons qu'on puisse les trouver mieux
que moi mais ce douce à petit d'où ça
vient pourquoi on ressent le besoin de
se comparer team est chez une fille en
taille justement l'exemple qui était la
couleur de mon chum on n'en a pas
vraiment parlé publiquement mais pour
moi ça a été très très très challenger
comme relation parce que c'est la
couleur de mon chum qui certaines
petites bottes des tentes et puis ça me
faisait capoter
mais d'un autre côté si ça vient avait
sorti son clip de trois ans quatre ans
cinq ans mettant j'aurais été la
première à l'applaudir oh mon dieu c'est
tellement beau temps dans le contexte où
ces facs pourquoi mettant une le
challenge pipe à un autre parce qu'une
réponse tant d'or qu'on s'est fait
exactement exactement s'il le que ce
simple portant le déconstruit pied c'est
ce que j'ai fait j'ai apprise en en
faisant mes gars tout le monde te trip 2
supprime moi ça bug va que c'est
clairement moins qu'un problème on peut
y aller sans parler puis merci mon dieu
elle a eu la grandeur d'âme de
m'accorder sauf qu'on est allé s'asseoir
on ne t on eu vraiment comme on a cru
mais l'action d'aller au coeur de tous
les deux on ne réaliser que dans le fond
on est inconfortable l'une avec l'autre
parce qu'on ce challenge est mais que ça
avait pas lieu d'être
je voudrais que de briser ce ça fait
tellement de bien de savoir que tu peux
traiter tout le monde avec autant
d'amour puis d'ouverture type je pense
que c'est le le vrai travail parce que
tu es en tout cas on pourra en parler
longtemps de ce disque j'ai vraiment
vraiment épineux est délicat mais moins
entre que j'ai l'impression qu'on est
tellement plus de facilité à accepter
quelque chose qui nous conforte puisque
une fille comme il en est tant que les
cinq fait des caisses d ab c'est comme
si c'est pour ce sexualisé manger de la
maison avec ce qu'on décide
des abbés pour ce sexualisé puis qui se
déshabille pour exister pour inciter on
peut tout juste nous laisser tranquilles
non non c'est vrai c'est juste que sur
les réseaux sociaux par contre souvent
le message féministe de tout mon corps
mon corps puis ma nudité m'appartient et
puis je peux faire ce que je veux avec
ceux souvent est accompagné de photos
qui quiconque or foule avec l'histoire
de moïse et oui c'est comme c'est le fun
la diversité corporelle pitié souvent
justement les textes qui vont
accompagner se voit être votre rôle
positif
sauf que ça reste souvent les mêmes
qu'en convoi à seafrance pour ce qu'est
qu'elle sa fiancée le très pertinent
parce que c'est la même démarche mais
avec un cas différent anciens puissent
satisfaire entre différentes qui de kate
moss ok mais son corps est pas si
différent de ça existe neuf pas une
excepté ça existe des filles qui portent
pas que du zéro c'est ce qu'il faut
qu'on commence à accepter c'est
dernièrement a posté une photo d'elle ou
est-ce qui est assis sur le banc la
piscine puis j'applaudis là j'applaudis
le l'entreprise de faire ce mais pour
moi ça soulève un autre problème qui de
dire est-ce que collectivement on est en
train de prendre a nice comme l'exemple
de la cèze sur instagram alors que selon
tous les standards de beauté à y
répondre et et peut-être peut-être un
tout petit peu plus de masse graisseuse
que les sags le modèle moyen que les
modèles moyen
si on compare avec les des gens normaux
aussi comme et comme à rendent
complètement les attentions l'instable
moyens et des jeux dans
l'autre aspect plus dans ce cas montre
les extrêmes ne ressemble pas tout ça
mais tu es cette photo la sexy s'y est
pas assis sur le banc une piscine un peu
recroquevillés comme akonga correspond à
tous les standards de beauté et plus est
en tant que société en fait comme en
bout en tant que que génération qui
regarde un sésame enfin comme good job
enfin enfin une grosse qui prend des
photos alors qui est petit est comme ça
rien à voir le cpie ça rien à ce que je
me disais on peut pas se prononcer pour
l on peut parler au complet en musique
on peut penser c'est de se dire mais
tant moi dans ma tête il doit avoir un
bon deux tiers de la population qui s'il
pleut sans surplus de poids qu'alanis
métier puis moi je me dis qu'est-ce que
ceux des ce2 pierlot se disent si comme
on applaudit ce geste là parce que on a
qu on dit ça c'est la diversité
corporelle
alors que non ça l'est pas c'est pas la
diversité corporelle puis moulin message
et dire je suis bien dans mon corps
j'accepte mais vergetures good parfaite
mais delà de commencer à comme un espèce
de raz-de-marée de 40 qui gagne on
s'accepte la gagne alors que finalement
on accepte encore un autre
un autre corps qui respecte les
standards quand on se donne le tuer mais
c'est passé comme si le monde a besoin
de se justifier ou de s'excuser je sais
pas quel point à l'anis que j'aime
beaucoup auraient publié cette photo là
sans rien dire c'est sa déception ça
avait été jean marc nobilo le décès
parce que c'est comme excuser parce que
l'attention est amenée vers ce autant
que une fille publié une photo en
parlant t2 borie positivity paix que
c'est pas nécessairement son combat elle
autant que de l'autre côté on peut
décrédibiliser une fille pascale fit
dans les stands or puis on veut comme
nous dévaloriser son discours en ce sens
bien tout est bio de toute façon on fait
un mauvais rêve et il faut apprendre
aussi à savoir qu'est-ce qui est notre
combat est celui des avants avant de
m'en venir lécher comme ryu j'ai de la
cellulite ans j'ai de la cellulite
j'ai des cicatrices j'ai du poil mais
comme toute chose comme ça ne représente
pas la diversité corporelle gens je
pourrais pas commencer à part ce serait
mais ce serait juste quand lancement
l'eau
de ma part mais grosses cuisses watts
gelé ça j'allais déjà fait cette erreur
le je suis énormément complexé par mon
agent c'est vraiment con on s'entend que
quelque chose de personnel
en effet ce qui m'appartient fille sur
une photo j'avais écrit je suis pris
comme un instant est ce que tu en vois
souvent des petits nés bosselé parce que
moi je voyais juste des petites
princesses de disney gens je les ai
faites en voit souvent tu te dis juste
dessiné plus à qui de loin ou quoi que
ce soit qui une fille qui m'avait dit
jean faux vrais pose pas des questions
le parce que ça a pas lieu d'être
qui savait si une grosse réflexion parce
que je me disais mais thil mettons moi
ça prend une grande portion de mon
énergie de mon temps est ce que ton
complexe au lieu d'être contée cph marib
est puis qui me disait jean moi je
trouve bien trop petit tour de bras je
pourrais peu je pourrai pas les valider
ce qui me dit ouais mais en même temps
je dirais mon galaxy
c'est extrêmement touchée justement des
kits qui l'intention derrière le message
derrière la photo tu sais parce que des
fois on voit des choses puis il y avait
quelque chose qui nous dérange quelque
chose qu'on s'y trame quelque chose de
pas net le mais la réelle intention la
connaît tout s'est vraiment dit si
justement de dire à qui est-ce qui est
pour les caisses qui pousse qu'est-ce
qui est qu'est-ce qui skient derrière
ces messages de sécurité
est-ce que c'est strictement pour qui ce
type de massage avec le type de photos
souvent plus de plus de l'accusation -
cc où c'est vraiment une réelle
réflexion et où un réel c'est tout on
est est un taux réel complexe tu te dis
mais on tourne et cie banque grecque
ben je traîne pas te dire taken 2
d'avancé je pense que l'important c'est
vraiment la discussion que ça soulève
aussi tu fais pas juste publié la photo
qui est en faute et dense en ce moment
je trouve que c'est juste important
qu'on en parle
de toute façon mais j'avoue que
j'aimerais ça commençait à avoir des
safiots nolin qui sortent leurs clips
des à l'année ce qui porte leur faute
qui posent leurs photos des landais qui
que ce soit qui a pu à se justifier par
époque le corps que tout peu importe
l'intention coûteux on en revient
toujours à la femme se justifie
d'exister prose café s'assume et
réellement je pensais le sable on
commence à changer
parce qu'effectivement puis la réflexion
est vraiment bonne de dire qu'est ce
c'est quoi qui se passe si mettons pour
regarder l'exemple dans la neige pour
que je me sente pas sur personne mais
qu'est ce qui se passait a publié cette
photo le 5 5 avenue c'est quoi
l'adac normalise pour vrai ouais mais
c'est l'excellent normalise pauvres
hères sauf que c'est ce postulat est pas
partagé pas et pavlik et autant ai pas
vu autant et poti probablement que ça
dit impose très normal
tout comme la photo marine gens que tu
t'inquiètes tout habillé puisqu'elle est
crié j'ai papoté montrer mes fesses et
des reines et crise écrit en photo avec
de 3,2 alors que celles à paris le réel
reste et même ce serait de le faire ça
sans parler de soi mais je peux
comprendre des fois qu'il est de le dire
sauf que je comprends c'est sûr que
c'était pour pousser tu vois que ça
dépend à quel point tu as vraiment une
soif de reconnaissance tienne je pense
qu'une coupe d'entre nous devrait être
capable de faire le deuil le de quelques
light quoi en plus c'est moi je l'aï vu
quand j'ai poster première photo que
j'ai posté de mes poils sous les bras et
je me suis ramassé jour même par une
trop lidge erreur lithium vous avez pas
dit en même temps moi j'étais ravie
parce que je voyais mon nombre d'abonnés
descendent mais je me dis je trie les
géoles le minage
c'est magnifique c'est comme dire aux
mosses monde le il s'élimine de lui-même
au td gallas le site trop pour moi
écoute je ne repasse jamais là-dessus
moi j'ai pas envie de te prouver que je
suis pas dégueulasse de laisser mon
corps vives de la façon qui vit
naturellement s'il alter puck bon vin
mon père de à dieu c'est un fait sa
préoccupation de quingey je commence à
parler de truc qui m'intéressait plus le
planer avec mam qui m'avait écrit alam
avait écrit là les livres l'entraînement
puis la nourriture le jeu tend à être
pas mal d'années et se fait pas autre
chose je vais arrêter de te suis je fais
beaucoup de chance que je fasse pour
autre chose
thierry d'entraînement du labour les
trois à voir qui me définit ce qui peut
arrêter monsieur oui si je ne sais pas
vraiment il y ait d'autres à porter un
vêtement n'est pas le cas non plus les
gens qui mangent les abonnés descendait
en épiant message déstabiliser comme une
espèce de l'autre il ya au 10 d'une
parenthèse le nom mais peut-être que
c'est vraiment lourd tu me dire mais est
ce que les gens ont demandé ici au
podcast c'est quoi cette affaire le
d'études universitaires - audrey le que
maintenant que j'ai accès à toi je veux
savoir est-ce que c'était fondé c'était
dessus sur un site de potins que partie
des remarques et le type arrow et
maîtrise les filtrations mével tration
l'infini oui j'ai un fils trait aux
dépôts en fait ce qui s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé c'est que moi je t'ai avant
de dalea aux occupations navarre et les
autres si on jetait la maîtrise en
littérature mon auteur de maîtrise
c'était intéressant thompson qui est un
journaliste kenzo kids en fond lui il
faisait de nouveau journalisme qui il y
avait à l'intérieur de ces sujets ce qui
est nouveau à nice mme steinbach des
années 60 aux etats unis c'est à des
journalistes qui infiltrait leur sujet
pour en parler mieux c'est pour le
décliner avec beaucoup plus de nuances
comme l'autre le livre sur lequel j'ai
travaillé c'était aux angels fait
contraste thompson et à les côtoyer des
hells angels pour expliquer pour aller
au delà de la nouvelle comme c'est des
bonnes manières italienne à naples en
italie
jeune auteur ajouté aux autres
d'installer c'était moins intense que
maintenant c est pas encore trop de
drogue là dedans puis c'est pas trop
organisé le c'était juste des
motocyclistes qui étaient comme des hors
la loi qui n'étaient pas conformes ont
été faits que là il est allé là dedans
pour expliquer comment ces gars là sont
rencontrés ensemble pour aix pour faire
un texte plus long de tous avec moi je
rentrais à travailler là-dessus l'on
s'en va à taiwan depuis - plus la bonne
après codé revient plus directe devrait
aller que le hockey je fais comme
nouvelle la mauvaise influence mais non
fiscales entre mi temps on fait un pari
lui était soit j'allais essayer de sûr
que je faisais 100 % disent que si je
donnais mon sens bourg sans jamais être
pris mais j'ai dit non ce pauvre est
fécond a parié 200 pièces je dois encore
et si deux suivants tu vas être pris moi
je n'en fais quand je vais aux auditions
finalement la minute que je rende dans
l'audition jeudi salut moi je m'appelle
parce qu'elle gauche puis auteur
généreuse plus j'ai vu c'était valdes
alpes et la productrice vivent dans sa
phase j'ai faim la soif à rodez puis
finalement quand j'apprends je le fais
le mof les jaguars ma directrice de
metric parce que ma maîtrise se faisait
en deux pinces usées je faisais mon
essai sur un tueur s thomson puis après
ce que j'avais une section création que
je n'avais pas encore de sujet mon mon
plan c'était de partir en moto faire le
tour des états unis puis de juste
d'écrire sur ce chemin mais je n'ai pas
de plans plus précis fait que la cage
je me suis assis avec ma directrice pour
conversation que j'anticipais depuis
longtemps où est ce que je fais qu'un
bon le il faut que j'arrête tout pendant
comme trois mois parce que je veux
occupation double mandat près des
poppers puis à fait clair qui est super
cool ce fait tourner au qui est vraiment
très très facilitantes dans tout ce qui
me dit ça serait intéressant de faire du
journalisme gonzo labo climat chez moi
c'est une bonne je dois voir si ça se
prête rendu la boîte fait le fait que le
tissage aura joué à haut débit ce qui
s'est passé ces quinze sorties des bleus
j'ai fait notre vue aux devoirs ou est
ce que j'expliquais ce puits l'entrevue
était super l'entrevue était c'était
vraiment un dialogue le ti c'était
vraiment bien écrit piste et catherine
lalonde de voir qui est vraiment ce
programme est une poète le tpiy c'était
vraiment un superbe entrevue j'en étais
très fier
puis ça a expliqué exactement ce que je
viens d'expliquer le tout en nuance le
coeur et le sensationnalisme le most été
si j'ai expliqué que c'était pas sur le
plein mais que c'est devenu que quand je
suis allé là je dis crime je pourrais
peut-être faire ce que j'explique dans
l'article qui finalement est arrivé là
j'avais connu jesse et puis mon plan
avait pris le parti pis là je commence à
travailler sur le véganisme pitié sur
l'extrémiste dans le véganisme puis tout
est à faire là c'était fait exprès dans
l'article maintenant tout
les webzines bénard city à leweb pq en
vedette ont sorti des articles avec le
titre bat en ph infiltrés occupation de
pilotes des espèces de tag line et comme
nous sommes tous pris pour des cons puis
tout d east side à faire clic babe
possible mais c'est soit parce que ça
fait tout un personnage tellement
intéressant tu parles du gosse sweet qui
s'entraînent qui a trouvé l'amour
honnêtement il n'y a pas grand chose à
dire là dessus lille va bien avec sa
blonde l'agente dégueuler respectives et
tout le monde fait un maquillage jouer
dans le tout le monde puis puis le fait
qu'après ce j'ai reçu un énorme backlash
suite à quelque chose que j'étais super
fientes l'article dans le vote comme un
accomplissement pour moi c'était
vraiment hot le tipi il ya plein de
monde quand allez vous suicider devant
tout le monde qu'ils lisaient de voir le
monde qui lisent leur sit in
puis pas tous pas toujours les mêmes il
n'y a pas trop de traces over qui en
dessous l'article devoir y avait plein
de monde qui disait ah vraiment
intéressant comme article quelle posture
on n'a pas souvent des gens de télé
réalité ça mais je laisse acheter super
contente le lendemain toutes sortes
le joueur des défendent nos digues sont
comme fâché après mois à cause qui ont
juste lui ce puits hâte que ça a été
c'est toujours là que ça se cache il
faut arrêter de nous rire sur les
magazines à paris tous deux avec sa me
fais de la promo constamment l'egypte
non mais ça fait de la promo nous
apprennent à faire qu'on a fait de notre
livre de recettes il était repris à dany
long et des lettres c'est sûr que ac est
un jeu qui est chiant vraiment fait que
financer seule histoire derrière tout ça
mais c'est un sport que je trouve qui
est dommage qu'ils aient beaucoup plus
de monde à être accroché sur ce ça a été
mal compris par plusieurs types saada du
gaig finalement qui se justifie d'avoir
fait ce qu a exercé que moi ce soir
après ma maîtrise je lis le comme les
époques mais c'est mais c'est ce en même
temps comme j'ai dit j'avais j'ai une
entrevue qui est sorti ce matin
la presse avec cassivi ou en revenait
sur juste pour influencer tout petit mot
la phrase que je répète depuis le début
c'est que si on est à ce point là
pertinent dans la sphère culturelle mais
on veut le prouver maudite marde
si on n'est pas obligés de s'assurer que
tout le monde le sache présentement
c'est tout tu dis les gars moi je ne
maîtrise jusqu'à 1go smart je pense que
j'ai quelque chose à apporter dans 10
ans le monde se dire ben coudon il ya
des raisons le godot des on dit accepter
il ya fait son chemin on n'est pas
obligé le tout le temps de vouloir que
les gens nous voient comment ces
produits finis non confiance que si tu
veux tu as ta place tu t'es bien parti
ça va bien pour l'instant
ouais tout s'est déjà vu critiquer
l'élément de stores et compagnie ces
spécialistes et auquel raison qu'est ce
qui risque d'agacer baisse fait suite à
la photo de max gourgues hockey ou et où
je posais c'est pour moi c'était déjà
l'aide des photos super rebelle
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui était érotisant montre que c'était
vraiment j'avais une toute une coiffe de
montrer les cheveux puis mais l'article
que monster pour les nommer aux sorties
s'appelait rosalie bon enfant pose
complètement nue dis moi je vois se dit
le jeu martin à ce que genre joignent
complètement nu les pôles france
complètement nu coeur de pirate bay 6
finalement c'est que ça ce qui m'a
dérangé c'est que faire des articles
comme ce petit l'arctique était super
fins et lost et comme vous alliez les
féministes ont l'homme dans ce qu'il
fait mais c'est que faire un article
comme ce sacre est un espace où les gens
se donnent le droit de donner leur
opinion qui est pas toujours la
bienvenue ou 13 il compte commencer sur
le problème c'est que pourquoi pourquoi
tu as besoin de créer une plateforme
pour attiser la haine
oui au pire supprime ces commentaires le
mais moi si je comprends que j'ai mis
cette photo leur public
mais pourquoi met-on sur mon compte à
moi personnel ou c'est les gens qui ont
choisi de suivre qui me suivent
personnes disaient que je mérite de me
faire violer mais que surmonte de stores
oui oui
c'est que les gens ont peut demander de
voter photo le moi j'ai pas demandé à ce
que les gens voient cette photo le par
il ya vraiment juste l'intermédiaire
loquillo chier dans les eaux faisait
prendre ce qui l'exposé à des gens qui
vont exactement qui est même tribunal
j'ai un peu fait une montée de lait on
me dirait ce qu'on peut arrêter de
prendre des termes en fut-il sur la vie
des personnalités québécoises puissent
faire comme si tu étais pertinence parce
que deux jours avant c'était vous n'en
croirez pas vos yeux mari me change de
tête
deux jours après c'était céline porte
une robe ou où on peut tout voir elle
dévoile tout puis je me dis à nos côtés
il me semble que c'est les noms n'ont
plan on peut en parler longuement son
besoin de parler de ta robe d'affilée si
je pense juste pas que c'est ce qui est
plus intéressant de faire comme si c'est
tout ce qu'ils avaient à dire sur la
personne ne sait vraiment capitaliser
sur des futilités
c'est à votre crise atypique but avec
faire des tempêtes dans des verres d'eau
prendre la partie non pertinence sur le
dos des jeunes puis c'est ça sur le dos
tu sais toujours d'aller chercher
notamment acquis des personnes connues
qui dit fonder des truc banal juste la
photo est espère belometti sa mairie de
pau mérite pousse à l'article mais si ça
aurait pu être l'arctic le coloris
smacks groupe sort une nouvelle photo
avec plein d'influencés sa retraite ce
bon mais le fait que ce soit ciblée sur
la fille qui avait pas de shanghai
si j'aurais aussi bien pu porter une
camisole échancré sur le côté ça arrive
la même chose de positionner sa com slt
trompe vraiment du gros sensationnel
c'est toute leur choix de titres parce
que tu du moment que tu lis se pose
complètement nus des jeunes à fignon
mais de légers voiles arctique mais déjà
les unions des clips à l'article r
c'est encore une autre qui se met une
heure
et si james maintenue sur internet 91
déjà cessé déjà ultra tinter comme titre
tout va qui se sait qui est qui la marge
puis j'ai c'est drôle je faisais blague
coeur de pirate mais elle a tout le
monde en parle avait dit qu'elle avait
décidé d'arrêter de faire des entrevues
à cause de ce jeu fait plus l'entrevue
parce qu'ils m'ont ils vont se rendre de
quoi ils vont le mettre sur déclic by
depuis je suis l'entrevue a quand même
ce qui est une bonne posture dans son
cas ce que je pense au cas besoin de
faire des entrevues
c'est que c'est tellement stressé c'est
tellement stressant faire des entrevues
le t1 podcast est différent parce que
d'abord une conversation du rebond de
montage le sud mais à part ce petit mais
merci c'est tellement court
ces bombes et nous on a monté un dossier
de recherche on va te parler de ceux sur
qui on veut s'assurer qu'on parle d'eux
sauf ceux et à bord se voit si t'es six
minutes pour vendre l'entièreté de la
personne que tu es à plein de gens qui
te connaissent ni d'eve ni d'adam sais
c'est de dire ben plusieurs fois dans
l'année qui va faire une première
impression qui va être très médiatisé
cette fois le thé content que ce soit
pas ta première impression qu'ils
arrêtent de me plaindre c'est pourquoi
nous sommes maintenant capables basse a
fait le tour du premier épisode c'est
quoi le truc
oui après ça y est après c'est avec quoi
que mais comme comme sujet mais
attention les fait pas les us et les
quittant résonner le plus longtemps le
minimalisme ça m'a vraiment marqué ouais
parce que j'ai dû vivre le challenge de
porter seulement je pense trois morceaux
quatre ou cinq morceaux en tout cas
pendant une semaine
mettez moi je suis en effet que qui
ferme ses portes d'armand de force ou
fax et ça me met ça me choque et pas mal
de réaliser à quel point j'avais
beaucoup de choses et surtout au niveau
vestimentaire ou s'était plaint un autre
niveau il à tous les niveaux c'est le
minimalisme le comme ce que j'ai appris
moi je pensais que c'était juste une
tendance pour justifier le fait que tu
es trop cheap pour t'acheter des
décorations
nous allons je me dis voyons on en
revient man et des murs blancs qui des
divas épuré mais j'ai compris que non
c'est vraiment un mode de vie qui
s'applique à même la personne que tu es
c'est aussi dans les relations de dire
il ya tellement de relations que je
continue je continue d'entretenir
ils y ont toujours été dans ma vie sans
me demander si je vais rencontrer
aujourd'hui est-ce que je repartirai pas
que ça et socialement le nombre le
nombre de relations qu'elle entretient
qui t'amène plus rien qui te demande du
temps puis que de temps en temps tu vas
aller prendre un verre ex personnes là
mais un peu par obligation que demande
juste pour entretenir pour entretenir ou
même sens que ça juste des gens qui te
ressemble plus qu'un thème encore mais
qui trust en plus c'est moi j'ai pas
envie de mon tour et de personnes qui
ressemble à la fille que je t'ai bleus
cinq ans j'ai envie de m'entourer de
personnes qui ressemble à celle que je
suis présentement et celle que j'aspire
à être pis pour ça que je trouve ça
difficile la vingtaine parce que c'était
dans une période définie un peu au
québec est ce que cet ami love tes amis
parce qu'on se voyait cinq jours par
semaine
constamment tué pendant cinq ans ou ben
non non on se ressemble vraiment
foncièrement dans ce qu'on ait été qui s
est une partie du minimalisme qu'on
soupçonne pas
en tout cas c'est une belle vague de
laisser khalid fort mais l'aja tous les
nouveaux exact opposé ce témoin c'est au
juge
j'imaginais ça vraiment au niveau des
débits des positions mais c'est vrai ça
m'aide vraiment une autre dimension
ça porte à réflexion toi est-ce que ça
tu habitais sata beach ou encore cette
espèce de recherche le de minimalisme oh
oui oui définitivement surtout d'être
jeté en appartement hautement garde-robe
sont bien trop petit je peux pas
continuer d'acheter des garde-robes mais
non puis surtout été personnellement je
suis vraiment dans cette recherche le
plus handicapant à chaque fois que
quelqu'un a une opinion différente comme
lors on est sans que la mi mai c'est pas
facile de couper des liens avec des gens
non mais je pense que eric burgaud
tuyaux jeunes amis non non non tu viens
en bonne et due forme le tu le fais en
bonne et due forme dit notre relation m
partant d'un moment clé c'est pour faire
comme web gars là on est due pour avoir
tant pis mais moi ce que j'ai constaté
c'est que la difficulté qu'on a à faire
le move est vraiment minime en
comparaison avec le position avec le
pouce titre ça
je sais juste de plus avoir à forcer
tout petit monde pas le temps de faire
ça dans vie tant que se donner de notre
temps à des gens qu'on n'a pas envie de
voir
sachant que je peux ça peut être vu
comme égoïste mais je pense que c'est le
genre d'égoïsme que je suis très
heureuse aussi moins savent mais ça fait
sens ça résonne beaucoup en moins que
toi que j'ai beaucoup de ces relations
mais moi je suis comme moi je suis quand
même minimaliste en général comme j'ai
pas beaucoup de choses à mon nom le
vraiment paul puis j'essaie de faire
attention parce que quand j'ai vidé la
maison mes parents quand mes parents
sont séparés je me suis dit non comme ça
c'est pas jojo jamais là dans ma vie il
était d'abord des bottes des boîtes de
bois de cosenza cumul qui disent des
trucs neufs qui sont encore dans le
plastique pots verte idée cadeau de 4 1
des d astaffort qui savent plus à
personne
puis fait clairement j'ai une règle chez
nous ça c'est pour les biens c'est
cadeau si vous voulez me faire des
cadeaux c'est un restaurant dont ceux ci
un cadeau ne veut pas recevoir de
cadeaux j'ai pas besoin de rien un
cadeau aux tenté de me dit en des voix
du temps où jean remettant une carte
cadeau dans l'eau ou au resto ou c'est
des trucs que moi je peux faire des
expériences passées mais plus de biens
ou de donner sa fête avait vu juste oui
certes ce facebook nous donne maintenant
l'opportunité de donner notre fête à une
cause quoi que ce soit qui me tient à
coeur
l'arrivée de tes amis à au lieu de
baisser un certain montant pour te
gratter pour aider des gens qui en ont
peut-être que je vois une belle
initiative vraiment vraiment puis mes
méthodes entendent soulever de me dire
cette espèce de version la de pas me
sentir trop encombré qu'est ce qui se
passe je sais de l'appliquer à ma vie à
- le jeudi 6 ans n'ayant aucune des
c'est quoi la réponse parce que je
réfléchisse à voix haute mais pas c'est
la première fois que que j'ai en tant
qu'homme cette version l'analyste c'est
super intéressant vraiment
et oui parce que deux parmi tous mais je
pense que c'est notre taille qui est la
plus encombrée oui c'est sûrement des
petits soucis préoccupations que si tu
élimines au moins une source de soucis t
souvent les gens toxiques dans notre jeu
au real espère qu'ils sont toxiques
avant qu'ils soient partis ça peut
prendre des années des années des années
d'abus ou de toit rabaissé ou de rien on
commence à ce que je me sens dont mais
jamais bien à chaque fois que je quitte
cette personne le pour finalement
réalisé après coup que up et 8 et
c'était vraiment drainant puis je
donnais beaucoup plus et coiffer tout le
monde au départ terne complètement
différent mais c'est comme si on a peur
de mettre terme à des relations mais
pourquoi met-on en amour on peut sentir
qu'on a un gros plus qu'on est juste
ailleurs ou qu'on n'était pas des
chemins séparés mais on ne sait jamais
c'est comme si une fois qu'on avait
trouvé notre ami on était obligé de
garder pour la vie alors que on est tout
autant humains en amérique en coupe
c'est ça se peut qu'on évolue
différemment aux serments contre la
personne
c'est peut-être le monde entier par
contre souvent les chemins c'est pas
besoin de casser comme avec une ronde le
web comme le tien mettez tout à fait la
bonne et due forme ou entre que j'ai
jamais eu besoin de m'asseoir avec
quelqu'un paie dit moi je pense qu'on me
tarde trop différent mais ça a mené si
comme les amitiés les relations de se
nourrir quand une gravité plus proche
les autres vers mango cela personne non
mais si tu te fais invités au lieu de
monter rire tu peux dire ben ça me tente
pas vraiment aujourd'hui tu es juste de
commencer à mettre la table que of
peut-être que ça c'est moins bon genre
tu m'invites dans un rêve j'aime pas
c'est assez correct merci de m'inviter
ça m'intéresse c'est un plus petit
canton va te fais des fois c'est sur un
ordinateur en disque dur de football
défragmenter ça fait que tant il va
prendre toutes tes fichiers biwolé il va
probablement enlevé les fichiers qui
sont comme corbiau qui n'existe plus
vraiment qu'il va les mettre à la suite
de l'autre fait que capcom pas les
petits espaces blancs anti phishing sont
les mettons pour illustrer ce
grossièrement des fois des fois on
dirait que mon cerveau en ce moment
j'aurais besoin de défragmenter mons et
de farouk et enlève toutes les petites
marle c'est tout les clips dossiers qui
sont pas folles importants que sont le
plus longtemps qu prime qui y que tu as
pensé de temps en temps enlève son rex
après ça tu as commis 13 5 gros dossiers
coller de cinq dossiers comme ceux qui
dressent tout l'autre partie tandis que
je retiens c'est ce fait la liste des
choses même analyse des choses puis
rapidement tu vas faire la liste des
choses nos métiers tu écris ta liste des
maisons des choses que tu fais
régulièrement qu'ils occupent
ta pensée et puis autre face à la
maladie voire il va traiter m 4,5 à
faire c'est le travail qu'il est faux
phare à qui je me concentre là dessus il
reste peut-être ce nom me devrai oui
c'est bon si vous pouviez vous
désencombrer de quoi que ce soit dans
bâti présentement en claquant des doigts
le sait fait pour vous qu'est ce que ce
serait que ce soit une habitude ou de
dépendance ou une personne même si vous
voulez le faire d'un coup alors oui
jerry's pas fini - nicole en propre et
amis c'est vraiment une bonne question
moi j'ai l'impression que je le fais
quand même au jour le jour je me pose
ces questions le fait qu en ce moment
j'aime bien cc c'est pas de réponse mais
maintenant si tu travailles pas trop où
tu peux t'en danse théâtre at remplir
l'agenda juste pour dire que tu
travailles ou quoi que ce soit c'est à
dire quand même je suis sûr que je serai
sûrement ça c'est sûr que le ch
moi je suis vraiment éparpillés entre
québec et montréal puis j'aime les deux
places mais la route est difficile noté
l'ong s'inquiète pouvait fusionner puis
avoir un lieu et un mariage ou tout ça
passe ça serait cool enfin que je te
répondrais oui c'est une question
identitaire aussi je pense
question me dire est-ce que falloir que
je règle cette question à la tête de
mesurer ce que met-on je me vois
montréal
pour long pagne sait combien de temps ce
que je me vois mal ce qui est capable de
d'enlever la charge émotionnelle que
j'aimais tant avec la ville de québec sq
est capable de mesurer plus jamais tu
vas quitter le thé ou du moins dans un
futur rapproché problème s'il est
capable d'un madame me réveillais en
réponse à ce exact puis deux puis me
poser la question quand je suis mettons
au cas je prends mon short à montréal
quand j'ai pris dans le trafic s'y cache
prix des réparations quand je prie le
dans le métro quand s'y jeter cap si je
pouvais mais ton parce que là chaque
fois que quelque chose de négatif arrive
avec la ville de montréal sam est en
crise à chaque fois que je me dis qu'est
ce que je fais ici s'il pouvait enlever
son manteau ça pourrait être pire que la
réponse va venir naturellement à toi tu
sais j'ai l'impression quand atteint un
seuil d'impatience comme signe le raja
proche de sous oui mais c'est vraiment
intéressant même je vais enlever mon
jaquette pour ceux de la question
identitaire le moi je trouve c'est vrai
j'ai oublié de parler dans un micro je
conseille vraiment intéressant parce que
c'est dit on parle des relations ont
parlé ville et tout mais par rapport à
soi même les attentes qu'on se met qui
la façon dont on dont on le traite nous
mêmes
j'ai souvent l'impression que c'est basé
sur tellement d'expérience qu'on a vécu
tellement de choses qu'on a fait du
passé qu'on traîne encore tg c'est
peut-être que je parle pour moi même et
on sait ce que je trouve intéressant de
me dire j'ai tendance à aa a coulé un
peu dans le béton la personnalité que
j'ai puisque je suis en faisant ben moi
tout mon secondaire mes amis m'ont dit
que je t'ai tel genre de fille pas que
c'est ce que je suis mais c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant de s'arrêter
dix ans plus tard de certains moi je me
définis encore comme une fille voilée
vrai chez même pas qu'est ce que je
pourrais donner comme exemple comme une
fille
extravertie c'est comme si on s'est
tellement causé là dedans que tu arrives
à être convaincus que ces sommes étaient
être puce
c'est autant que je sais que j'ai déjà
été vraiment très jalouse avec mon club
le cpie de même mais je porte encore la
culpabilité d'être une femme jalouse
alors que je suis puceau pourquoi on
fait sauter pour qu'on s'attache autant
à l'idée de ce qu'on est
mais il semble que ça nous ont pas eu
tellement de cheminée salle au tâtre
confortant d'une certaine façon de
savoir d'abord un retard par rapport à
qu'est-ce que tu es tu de pouvoir mettre
des pièces de mettre une étiquette sur
des trucs qui est quelque chose de
réconfortant la demande qui de plus en
plus du moins j'essaie de le faire de
moins en moins je sais de ces épices et
des bd construit qui est le temps déjà
menés l'été la façon que j'ai été élevé
la façon même dont la façon que je vois
un couple le plus du para du monde pour
d'autres on parle à djawad si tu parles
est un gars comme j'attends vos
emplettes parts on copie dudit crise il
n'y a pas la même étiquette que j'aurais
mis sur le mien miniature en moins bien
et tu l'accès de tous à tout l'air
d'être besoin d'avoir ce est ce que j'ai
besoin de dire ah non moi je peux pas le
contraire au sol ont lâché le contraire
de toi apparemment identiques avec ce
que je suis vraiment introverti lorsque
les ondes dès que je me dis on embauche
introverti fait je prends pas part à x y
z d'activité menace que des activités
que je me bloque parce que je me dis
j'aimerais pas soit parce que je suis
introverti était très probablement
beaucoup de fois je dois rester chez
nous à misano ce jeune boxeur parce que
jamais mais ce puits mais c'est pas la
même chose à chaque fois ce pas les
mêmes gens qui vont être là pour le même
trip to be les fois où est-ce qu'ils
remettront j'estime convainc d'aller à
une place ça arrive rarement que je me
laisse convaincre d'aller en place mais
des fois que ça arrivait j'ai eu
vraiment le fun puis c'est sûr que des
fois que je partis de bonne heure mais
au pire c'est horrible mais on n'écoute
pas mettre mes donc mais pas dans
l'archétype que tu penses que tu es
réellement tepa dans l'identité que tu
donnes à toi même passer ça c'est
réconfortant les étiquettes mais en même
temps c'est un peu contraignant ça peut
devenir un carcan de dire tu es même
juste pour l'identité sexuelle un thé
tout le temps tous hétéros facture est
fermé aux possibilités jusqu'à ce que tu
réalises copains non ça ce petit
je pense qu'il faut juste pas voir ça
comme si c'étaient vraiment des murs
fermé sur toi tu peux ouvrir les
fenêtres leur garde à l'extérieur pin up
est que ce ça m'intéresserait finalement
pis je pense que c'est une belle façon
de est en constante évolution tout à
fait tout à fait puis de plus en plus
j'ai l'impression que que ceux qui ce
questionnement la sangle prendre de
l'ampleur dans le ton est un peu plus
tôt avait dans notre génération
l'impression que une espèce de désir de
d'ouvrir les fenêtres comme tu m'aimes
d'illustrer laitiers se faisait désirer
collectif de fort hare voyons ce que nos
parents nous ont ainsi parce que parce
qu'ici tu vraiment sorti c'est vraiment
ce que c'était et puis ici puis temps ce
cas-ci imputant ce que c'était vraiment
puis et puis on en parlait ce matin
seulement avec jesse sur le poker
on leur su par rapport à peu par rapport
en lien avec la parade la pride hier
tpiy il ya plein de monde qui vont à
parade pas parce qu'ils sont dans des
diversité sexuelle juste parce qu'ils
veulent embrasser le choix c'est le
choix de france qui tue le choix de pas
avoir de restriction de tous les niveaux
puis je trouve quelque chose que c'est
une belle époque des dans laquelle on
vit présentement à un certain niveau
c'est sûr qu'à d'autres égards c'est pas
mal mais à ce niveau là au moins c'est
la femme de ménage une chose qui a
enregistré des demandes et repose la
question une seule chose que je fais
minelli flyff fly away
c'est une bonne question je vous ai posé
ça brûle pourpoint comme cité par une
question comment que ses réponses et
comme et pourquoi tu le fais pas ouais
les accessits accessible dès que japon
domaine et ce sont les bonnes questions
et oui c'est ça le mettrait le pied en
même temps c'est vrai hâtif faisons-les
on est tellement imprégné par l'apport
plein d'affaires mais je pense que si je
devais me débarrasser d'un encombrement
présentement ce serait vraiment c'est
vraiment maudit troupe des steam qui me
suit depuis bien trop cher en psy le
signe de soi c'est comme si c'est
vraiment bizarre expliqué c'est comme si
c'est un démon que j'ai apprivoisé puis
que j'ai appris à être justement presque
rassuré de le voir de ces médias moi je
suis de même moi j'ai une fille qui
doute d'elle même c'est normal que je
pleure après les entrevues ben c'est
normal que je me pousse jamais allé plus
loin parce que je suis de même je suis
un problème d' estime je n'aime pas
assez j'ai pas assez confiance en moi
c'est comme si je les tellement nommé ok
j'en suis tenue elle justifiée alors que
ça a vraiment pas lieu dans la vie de la
famille inquiète qu'on parle tantôt ou
qu'elle aurait s'accrocher exactement
qui déjà mon chef m'a posé une question
qui m'a vraiment saisi récemment il me
dit est ce que tu as l'impression que tu
restes un peu accrocheur et romans parce
que tu as l'impression que ça définit
comme personne puis le je l'espère
personnel évidemment qui touche une
corde sensible
j'ai réagi quit et je sais comme si j'ai
tellement eu une belle vie que je me
suis accroché à tout mais petit bobo
pour me dire bain seuls ses l'apport
humaine en moi alors que je vais être
humain de toute façon ces facs mais je
pense que je me détacherai d'autres
puis je me dirais non à partir de
maintenant j'ai le goût d'avoir
l'étiquette la fille confiante de la
fille du fonds depuis qu'il s'excuse pas
d'exister pis je pense que je dégage un
petit rush que tout projet mais
j'aimerais beaucoup là qu'il s'en tirer
c'est un travail constant le malchanceux
depuis tout petit
non non non non non quand j'étais petit
opprimant j'avais une estime béton
équilibre gens l'ont jusqu'aux chevilles
des petits cheveux tout corpo de bain
mais je me trouvais belle je me trouvais
autres je me trouvais tombe était au
dessus de la mer
finalement je tu arrives au secondaire
je me suis dit ah ben non finalement pas
mal tout le monde est belle et
intelligente et tapis le gepan ya un mur
pigiste est comme ton densité de se
déprécier dans le vestiaire lost et
comme c'est comme la mode de faire mais
moi j'étais trop bondée troc rob ramage
est trop gros coup fait que je suis
juste embarquer là dedans jusqu'à
finalement vraiment croire et c'est là
que j'ai fait une gaffe le cerveau est
vraiment puissant puisse convaincre de
bonnes affaires tac love comme dans une
déprogrammation de me convaincre que non
non je suis pas tout ce qui a bien fait
mon affaire de me dire que je t'ai été
le très clair comme proche de bain mais
ouais mais c'est tellement c'est
tellement lucide comme comme
raisonnement comment tu leur expliques
comme city puis ça rend cela encore plus
le ton exemple est parfait mais même
pour pau
pratiquement tout ce qu'on dit tantôt ça
rend ce qu'ils m'ont encore encore plus
incompréhensible qu'on soit capable
chasse et si ce deal
parce que les câbles d exprimer
tellement alarmant
aucun mot juste problème le cg mais qui
se veut semer cette voie d'une petite
médecin manif j'ai trouvé ça tellement
intéressant c'était notre première
rencontre parce que je vais déménager
papier comme changer si tu lèches
expliqué qu'ils jetaient kiddouch venez
plonger très bas
j'ai vécu telle affaire pileux j'ai eu
un tel combat dans ma vie at-elle niveau
vient me dire aux halles itunes sommes
tellement tout à prendre au jeu ça vive
tu apprends donc juste à ressentir les
choses vraiment telles qu'elles sont
sans vouloir les pointer du doigt pis
c'est comme ça on a tendance a vraiment
été lecture alizés tout ce qu'on vit
mais que c'est que ça nous empêche de
talent et coûte réellement de ce qui se
passe en nous parce que c'est là que
c'est plus facile de tomber dans nos
barton de mémoire et une fille de même
fac c'est normal que je réagisse comme
ce lundi que si on enlevait et toutes
ces idées là qu'on s'est fait de nous
qu'ils comptaient juste aider des petits
points le libre et 20 exigés
je pense qu'on serait plus doux avec
nous tu consens pardonnerait beaucoup
plus parce qu on se dirait pas au boulot
j'ai acheté même si ce n'est pas
vraiment moi t on est tout le temps on
est tout le temps de même le fait même
temps on s'éloigne un peu ou qu'on rate
je pense qu'on aurait quand même plus de
douceur avec nous si on se mettait pas
la pression de quitter dans quoi que ce
soit je change aucun d'eux la petite
fille qui était confiante le justement
la dispo trop consciente de ce qui a
projeté métier mais qui tente vous donne
le ton ce que tu essaies de renouer de
retrouver sa petite fille le ouais parce
que tu là et étaient capables de lancer
quand j'aborde souvent c'est l'idée de
me retrouver
on veut donc bien se trouver dans vie
alors que je pense que c'est là l'erreur
c'est qu'on se cherche
comme si on n'était pas des jeux le
temps je pense pas que cette fille là
elle existe juste quand même une partie
de moi que j'ai pas tellement tu dis
j'avais tellement peur de faire mauvaise
figure si je t'aime fille confiante
j'avais peur de passer pour une fille
prétentieuse ou égocentrique que je lis
vraiment comme j espère my last petite
voix leur simple maintenant j'essaie de
l'écouté je la trouve plus j'attends
vraiment puppy je pense que je dois
juste la reconstruire un peu comme s est
construite à force d'encouragement de ma
mère qui me triper dessus comme ça avait
pas de bon sens parce que si je
commentais je me tape tellement ça
tellement d'affaires que si je me
donnais au moins l'occasion de faire
l'inversé comme tu disais tantôt faut
prendre la critique possible est négatif
si je me permettais de considérer les
compliments que je reçois avec avec la
la même chose comment dire ce traité
soit avec la même
je suis mytho la légitimité ou à merci
ben je pense que le à pourrait revenir
le pitch parler au conditionnel mais
ouais je pense que je pense qu'il faut
juste en fait faut juste arrêter dois
tout
mais oui tout réfléchir tout les mêmes
blessures family régler une fois pour
toutes je parlais des amis lo'jo piste
demain 10 piges leur demander c'est 6,6
à quel moment dans ta vie que tu as
perdu ton innocence
parce que non mais je t'ai pas la cerise
et qu'on a tout des moments dans notre
vie charnière où est-ce qu'on était naïf
qui amendait north une claque dans fast
génomique est mal à ma vie je veux te
raconter un la première fois je pense
que j'ai perdu mon innocence
ces bougies 10 par an dont j'ai été
élevé leur a menti avec des bonnes
valeurs pitch un bon petit groupe était
juste et bay street puis ben correct et
puis ne pas être stricte c'est très
correct aussi exceptionnel à tour bien
ouais non mais je prends le bar
exceptionnel qui aura des tyrans de
bonnes personnes avec une belle personne
bonne dynamique belles valeurs puis-je
hérité de se bouger parce que j'étais le
fruit de se mettre en gage et des jeunes
la prime et ses mythes pis je peux t'en
souviens même on a jamais reparlé je
pense mais ammann et le il ya eu 1
partez à shannon mais qui quant aux
seconds ne fait pas de quelqu'un qui ta
pièce for love cette personne le jeu
l'adar beaucoup plus encore une amie
puis j en veux pas mais il ya une fois
où est ce que moi je n'étais pas présent
ce parti-là qui perd j'étais là parce
que on en mangeait tous les deux mais en
tout cas on compensait n'est pas au même
niveau que moi j'étais en compétition
plus les dépôts 8 et aux parts et puis
je me souviens quelqu'un je suis revenue
la compétition puis j'ai demandé à péage
est il parti cet iphone vite leurs
droits étaient typiques comme bolt et
[Musique]
clairement morgan
j'ai répondu plus tu tournes et au fait
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que je sais
c'est qu'il n'était pas normal qu'on ait
vraiment des jeux télé quesqu'il puis
légende il pleut je voyais les côtes
planète qui il les mélodies ou bailly
m'a dit tu demanderas à table en
bâtiment à table on ou jouer ses droits
exactement parce que le jsuqu'à laver
comme spoon et dormi échos les cagots
prendre assez de ce puits c'était une
époque où est ce qu'est faire se tait
quand j'avais passé une tonne innocence
on dirait que c'est un construit cantona
et lens inconditionnels ont les gens
tellement des bons que ce thème avec ses
modestes amendes les modèles tellement
bon que je pouvais imaginer que des
choses comme ça ça arrive vite
c'est comme un gros ça va avec lequel ça
arrive ça a été la première claque d'en
face le genre dans vraie vie il ya des
démarches comme ce qui t'as réussi où il
ya des idées à faire connaître qui se
passe que le monde se font ce qui a été
dit ce jour là j'ai perdu un petit peu
moins d'essence
je devenu c'est plate à dire mais un
petit pull moins bonne personne je pense
j'allais justement tu ai demandé est ce
que tu penses que ça fait de toi un
meilleur jeune aujourd'hui on dirait que
je m attendais à ce que tu me dis non
non je pense pas ah ouais non moi je
pense que je t'ai juste juste dans la
confiance juste à donner puis juste dans
le positif des script ce jour là je suis
devenu un peu un peu plus aigri un peu
plus méfiant un peu plus
qui a en relation il faut aussi qu'ils
trient taille
je peux vraiment dire savoir la de côté
nos métiers on dit que tu fais là bas
j'ai repris si lyon s'est laissé j'ai
repris avec mais on dirait que le
j'avais comme le genre de pouvoir le
pouvoir comme culpabiliser la wii c'est
d'abord d'avoir ce tir peut pas utiliser
sud peut pas se servir de ce c'est
surtout que ça a été ça profite pas toi
non non mais c'est aussi toute une
journée en tête à toi - cardiff city fac
et oui c'est ma mère j'ai perdu mon
innocence médecin il y en ad'autres le
petit moment même où est ce que si tu
fais des affaires 8 arrêts d affaire qui
durait jamais le même mais avec le recul
tu pas envie de voir ça peut te dire ben
j'ai appris que en amour on n'est pas
imperméable à ce que la personne avec
qui on est soit attiré par d'autres
ça s'applique à toi aussi tu es toi non
plus tu es pas imperméable à ce sa
trempe pas plus mais ton conscient de
dire mon gars on sème en connaissance de
cause pour un pion s'il y en a d'autres
mais on choisit quand même d'être
ensemble parce que ça vous l'avez
peut-être que ça va ressurgir mais tu
vois j'ai jamais vraiment j'ai même
repenser vraiment à ce truc le avant
qu'on ait ces discussions le avec mes
amis puis maintenant pas de juste le
fait de nommer ça te fait réaliser ses
dauphins le csa réalisé 7 a marqué plus
que d'y penser ça te fait réaliser aussi
que ça explique certains comportements
acteurs qui sont un comportement qui tu
veux peau à voir avec le justement dans
des relations après ça plus si tu le dis
repas avec justement peut devenir une
moins bonne personne mais se dire avec
ouais je peux plus en soit conscient ce
quart est soi-même à christ fils et j'ai
commencé j'ai eu ma première mon premier
meeting comme ça s'est passé
comme je m'assois privé de soule et un
homme ou toute autre porte pas vraiment
ça ce magasin 12,1 un monsieur un
évident au début il ya une nette
en fait il me demandait le lien vers le
podcast c'est d'entendre may et comme si
le peuple ils regardent au prince me
regarde c'est pas les bonnes et même au
ph alors dis mais pas ce que je t'ai je
parle je parle encore un peu n'importe
quoi puis l'heure on sait pas quoi dire
ben monsieur nous a amené naturellement
moi visite comme un flot moussa sow lui
comme un flot de pensées mais tu sais
pas pourquoi tu te soumets je le dise
pas ça doit être pertinent si ce qui
vient
exonhit entend par arriver est ce qui
compte ce qui est exactement pipi comme
le fait le tir 45 peuple n'a pas dit
grand chose pendant 45 minutes la afin
fait jusqu'à me dire mais tu pense pas
que ce soit puisse créer sur le chevet
jour j a déjà serré que mais ces
crissements bon pour une première encore
une peur bleue depuis comme rendu chez
nous pour certains à faire avec ça en
tête
comme j'y repense toujours pense
activement comme ses conseils leur puis
je me dis qu'il est des affaires que je
fais des comportements que j'ai des
façons de gabor des relations avec des
personnes me dit ménage conscient de
pourquoi j'ai agi de cette façon lui
mettons ou du moins j'ai peut-être une
piste de raison d'une piste de
raisonnement qui fait que à chaque fois
je me pose la question que je me dis
comme ok excuse est-ce que c'est tout
seul apparaît plus claire des jeux
puis ça ça fait quelqu'un quand même
temps parce que des situations
conflictuelles comme ce que tu veux
raconter de poser la question moment que
ça arrive
le câble daté d'avant la lucidité mettre
un troisième personne qui est seule à
cette situation le sait quoi laisser
quoi que c'est pourquoi c'est arrivé
qu'est-ce qu'on a retirés c'est quoi
comment toi en tant que personne soit de
l'avant ce jeu tant conflit 10 août à
quelque chose commence va de l'avant en
devenant mieux c'est quand tu améliores
développement personnel mais ça prend
beaucoup de contrôle sur soi thé dansant
soustrot à feu facile
tout à fait mais c'est vrai que quand tu
arrives à utiliser ces outils le parce
que tu es là la thérapie ce pas comme tu
consultes une fois que vous vous jure
c'est sûr twilio leur de consultation
mais il ya surtout beaucoup de travail
passe à nouveau en découlent dit
justement mon psy d'apprendre à utiliser
ces outils le dans les situations
conflictuelles
j'ai commencé à voir sommes un peu d'un
extérieur si on était dans une télé
réalité si avec quelqu'un qui nous
regardaient présentement est ce que je
regarde une maudite folle
devant la réponse c'est oui tout ça m'a
aidé à corps ce qu'a lieu de phoning
enfin quelqu'un qui te regarder si on en
perd mais tellement le pont mais s'ils
avaient une tierce personne qui vous
jugent l e je pense qu'on modèles
réduits absolument mais oui c'est titre
personnel ça doit être soi-même neuf on
le tient mais dites moi l'affinité qu'on
fait quelque chose qu'on n'aurait pas
faire défaut au niveau quand même puis
faut il faut il faut il faut être
capable de police
moi ça me donne un jardin volante ou des
cuisses canche et que j'avais quelque
chose de pas correct
j'ai des frissons des crises a choisi
vrai mais à quelque chose de paul von
teese pouvoir apporter face ou à quelque
chose de paul von next non genre mettant
je m'appelle qu'une fois leveleux
plusieurs années je voulais aller
fouiller dans celle de mon chum puis en
le prenant le j'avais eu des frissons
partout en tout des cuisses qui ont un
accès mon corps qui me disait rosie est
passé vraiment pas l'egypte ouais mais
non c'est ça se fait ça fait pas ce
qu'en je me chicane mais tandis que je
sens que plus de
la ligne directrice le faudrait que
j'aille s'est signalé par le sandwich
baden mairesse développent moins ça se
développe la question de la télé-réalité
c'est vraiment bon tout candidat au dif
thomas est ce que ce que tu avais le
3eme qui disaient non on est intéressant
qu'on n'était pas conscient on ne sait
pas conscience de soi par contre si ce
que tu peux analyser mettons en surtemps
le globe c'est la personne que moi je
pensais qu'ils étaient le plus
problématique dans cette émission là le
québec au complet
retrouvez que c'est la personne la plus
problématique dans l'émission fait quand
tu regardes ton ces exercices là est
excellent et dc si ce que je fais en ce
moment été vu par quelqu'un d'autre
qu'est ce que cette personne ne
penserait soumettons d'une situation
complète
est ce que le juste en train de nourrir
mon ego mais dont pour essayer de gagner
un argument avec ma blonde par exemple
alors que quelqu'un regarde et du 3ème
fréquence même qu est le troisième ace
verrait que vous êtes dedans même team
si j'ai pas de guerre de kiki triomphe
le but c'est de faire survivre l'équipe
ouais c'est ça la cause de comme une
espèce de guerre d'ego des fois que tu
essaies de de gagner un argument que
donc on a sûrement raison de vouloir
augmenter vouloir pas vraiment de raison
de voir débat apport je sais pas un
essai niaiseries l'été le tout d'ici à
quelqu'un qui regarde elle creuse et
outils fois que je me trouve ce qu'il
fallait que je fasse
ouais ouais je me trouve une espèce de
d'image une personne juste à ma taille
d'écrire une espèce de créer une espèce
de personnages qui va toujours valide et
je me dis mais tombe cette personne est
impartial je me dis qu'est-ce que met-on
denis qu'est ce que denis penserait way
de ce que je tenterai neuf ans mais
denis denis il prend pas d'abord que ni
la suède la marre de te le dire à 100
que je fais là c'est de la grosse merde
ouais est-ce que c'était déjà arrivé de
toi même te littéralement devoir me ton
est d'édifier natalité l'avenir devoir
béton et enfin vidéo table angle plus de
fun montage après le métro entre les tec
et le pour que je parlerai demain
ty littéralement devoir d'être en
désaccord avec les propos justement band
est en tout cas est ce que ça t'a appris
sur toi comme regardait ce que j'ai pris
la gmao des la question à au dg j'étais
en désaccord avec une saveur que j'ai
fait leroy ph ont même c'est quoi même
pas ça à mener comme et agit comme
embarqué dans une clinique comme journée
à 20 plaintes comme michael mann fautes
qu'on remarque qu'on veuille éliminer
les nouvelles feuilles les quais mais ça
c'était juste mais comme je suis allé
voir son origine à taille humaine on le
nomme en soit je me suis vu j'ai fait
maintenant dans des caves appartements
mais c'était tout six photos dans un
contexte s'est fait prendre au jeu là
c'est un modèle m'a regardé pu voir ça
je suis moi je pense pas mais je voulais
faire et ai jamais pris la main dans le
sac
moi je pense que j'arrive et c'est ça
qui la cave
non mais je pense exactement c'est
adriano fait entre ses potes là ma tête
mais je les besoins sont déjà arrivés
juste à ma situation et notamment comme
sous l'étiquette voix mettons la en
vidéo haineuse qui oui pas être la
personne que je voudrais tu as la
rive-sud a des pattes à personnes qui
souffraient souvent soit souvent mais en
même temps ce que j'apprends c'est que
justement moi aussi quand je vais vite
et je me suis un peu près juste avec mon
chemin
on va bien mais comme la personne avec
qui j'aime étant le plus de conflits pis
- oui ça m'arrive
michi câble de réaliser que au banc
nantais j'ai vraiment horreur réagi et
le jeu trop orgueilleuse pour le dire je
trouve pas en veilleuse de faire comme
ben je te crie après depuis 10 minutes
mais finalement j'avais tort sauf que
merci sauf que je pense que on a peur
d'admettre vos torts parce que c'est
comme si on admettait compte un parfait
qu'on avait des défauts
pis c'est comme si
donner raison à l'autre personne de dire
aux raisons de trouver que c'est pas
correct parce que je peux grecque mais
en même temps quand on inverse les rôles
moi quand mon homme reconnaît ses torts
je le trouve mme arthur le trouve
intelligent ça me fait du bien qu'ils
soient de même ça m'aide à changer mon
mood fois que je me dis j'ai envie de
m'offrir cette satisfaction le de
revenir sur mon propos je dirais gta
morceau tout de suite j'ai eu tort ou à
raison c'est polt personnes aiment ça à
bordeaux mais la résultante est quand
même intéressante parce que des fois ça
sauve une soirée au complet ça sauf que
l'inde angoisse tout ça sature d'aller
trop loin ou t'as pas besoin d'aller kid
est arrêté puis de juste dire se mettre
ton ego de côté
ouais on dirait que c'est bon pour l'égo
de dire finalement j'ai été capable de
nous choisir pi 2 po choisir une voie
que j'emprunte juste pour l'été pourquoi
ultime ans ça nous apporte pas
grand-chose raison aucune raison elle
même temps qu'eux elle met donc denis
avaient toutes les informations c'est
une zone mais tandis qu'antti quand tu
quand tu tombes ce quelqu'un qui pendant
une bonne journée au camp d'une chicane
à quelqu'un ou quand souvent souvent les
clients quittent irrité parce qu'il
yad'autres par rapport à un sujet
excluent y ait quelque chose qu'il a
donc donné avec toutes les informations
ils pouvaient ils pouvaient voir où est
ce que tout vient le pro mac tout et
qu'on prenable moment toute réaction est
explicable
c'est par par un accumulation d'affaires
qui amène le puits une fois que tu ali
se dit on et tout paraît plus proche
qu'on pense
mais oui le juge exclut évidemment les
gens problèmes sévères dans les trois
séries et je calcule pas là dedans leur
comportement est sans doute pas
explicable peut-être explicable jamais
justifiable mais mais white je pense que
c'est important est capable justement
votre prononciation d'essayer de
l'analyser mieux que par les émotions
j'ai l'impression qu'ils de communiquer
aussi ses attentes c'est peut-être que
c'est complètement féminin comme
comportement de certains
parce que l'autre ce h 10 quand il y en
a pas deux ni qui va chuter à podium
aujourd'hui table on a eu une mauvaise
journée soit douter pourquoi on le fait
pas nous mêmes on attend denis mais on a
comme peur nous mêmes de dirait
aujourd'hui j'ai vraiment besoin qu'on
soit sûr ensemble parce que j'ai déjà
fleur de peau on le dit peu on attend le
hic
mais on est vraiment maître date notre
propre denis ouais c'est vrai l'autre
jour j'avais vraiment une journée de
mardi
j'avais genre une journée ça a été
extrêmement pénibles
je reviens chez nous ils étaient rendus
peu près de neuf heures le soir puis
comme j'avais jeté par l'âme le terme
and haas les juste dit à des seals
je suis allé courir j'allais courir par
mais pas avant que la cour est allée
courir puis après ça ça va me vider
l'esprit pilon pour parler de ce qui
vient de se passer lorsque le cerveau
comme neuf est à découvrir en sont venu
on s'est parlé de la journée qu'on vient
d'avoir on s'est parlé de ty toutes les
meetings événement si on a fait un petit
oui cap tout était banshee tu t'es pas
classé à mata est juste parce que tu
l'est comme redescendre le moment mais
on se retrouve sur ma chienne ici
puisque même pas qu'on se chicane à nous
laisser jusqu'à vais l'attention d'un
jour n'est même pas nous deux on se
serait juste chiant n'est sûrement parce
que j'étais trop petit je voulais pas
parler puis savez ça reste était négatif
pour tout le monde
sous-estiment le pouvoir d times croit
même que moi le jeu défend vraiment la
technique se coucher là dessus j'ai vu
un story toutes les coupes désole secret
de la longévité s'est jamais se coucher
forget mais mon l'oeil or rien qui me
fait plus de bien de ses vaches et
métiers quand on se couche pas chez moi
j'ai tendance quand ça va pas bien
vouloir le régler toute une vie en tant
que j'ai pas envie de lâcher tant que je
peux vraiment apaisée mais c'est quand
on esprits en corse on peut dans un mode
qui est prêt à être dans un état qui
études tu peux pas y arriver est entré
côte d'or
c'était en chicane mais toi avec ton
partenaire premièrement naturellement la
nuit tu finis par te colle été ton corps
comme parler à ta place fac tu te
réveilles des gens cuillère en dedans
mais le jeu sans cette rue
mais je tends la cuillère mais d'abord
dormi là tu le moi ça me fait tellement
bien le caillou dit c'est des petites
accroches on se dit on n'a pas besoin de
ce panier jusqu'à 4 heures du matin on
se couche en se couchant ce boudin
quitte demain matin c'est ça va être
déjà un peu plus insignifiante et le tas
fait souvent bien les choses puis la
nuit porte conseil
et voilà il y en a deux ou trois bons
joueurs disaient toujours vous 15 la
nuit conseil non mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai oui
puis c'est quoi c'est quoi justement la
nuit porte de garage
et voilà c'est un classique l'expression
mais j'ai la phrase on parle pas de
semaine on parle pas de semaine je veux
qu'on en parle pas de ça maintenant je
peux pas
puis comme des faits quand tu reviens
après c'est plus nuancé pas appliquer ce
qui est ressorti
initialement les gros torque toute
personne menaçant si perdu en un sens
c'est sûr que oui c'est sûr que oui mon
innocence relationnel je les perds du
jeu la mesure à faire confiance
maintenant je me suis pas trompé comme
quand même plutôt sauvage mais j'imagine
puis ça c'est long à reconstruire mais
ça c'est noir construit je pense que
j'ai perdu mon innocence à mancieulles
des microdoses mais c'était sans doute
une grosse c'est une grosse de khanfar
qui émanent pour le reste de ma vie
maintenant je veux voir ma tête je veux
dire - mais qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
abondamment fait pas que toi qu'est ce
qu'il est en train de faire c'est drôle
que tu y mets ton vous avez cette voie
là dans votre tête parce que vous avez
été trompés mais que techniquement vous
pourriez avoir cette voie là dans votre
tête en n'ayant pas été trompés ouais où
vous auriez pu avoir été trompé sans le
savoir ici bas rhin sud on en vient on
est vraiment maître de ce qu'on vit plus
de la finale qu'elles ont exactement le
maître le tronc pops c'est à toi même
seul d'entre eux n'ont cessé après que
le groupe cet optimisme absolument
mettez cette phrase là ou est ce qu'elle
est c'est un pour moi c'est un peu comme
quelqu'un qui
été accidenté petit club saïd a ouvert
les yeux sur la vie c'est comme ça on
attend tout le temps le wake up call
pour changer ou pour ceux d'aubin moi
mettons telle personne de ma famille est
tombé malade est parti ça m'a vraiment
ouvert les yeux sur à quel point la vie
est éphémère alors que que tu as perdu
quelqu'un ou pas la vie est-elle bonne
conduite en rendre compte
ben plus tôt puis autant que pour la
fidélité
tu peux avoir c'est voix loach
contiennent je pense que tu peux aussi
les déconditionner choisissant bon et
sans aucun doute sans aucun doute même
source j'imagine que c'est le teint qui
fait ce n'est déjà pas mal moins pire
que ça déjà été mais meiway le sens
perdue as tu perdu tout sens au dessus
des mamans qui te rappelle que tu as
fait les quelque chose doit changer pour
de bon
d'un mois ouais mais en même temps c'est
jamais vraiment pour de bon parce que
j'ai pas dit j'ai pas envie d'être une
personne gagnante
ouais je me dis ça me changeait pour
l'instant c'est ça ça a changé ma
conception justement d'un concept ou
quoi que ce soit mais je pense que la
vie est une série de petites cassures
c'est vraiment pessimiste peux te dire
cela mais si ya pas mal atavique à tes
enfants tu es vraiment brésil
ouais puis à marie tu te brisent une
première fois s'est brisé à coups de
fouet après sa 7e reconstruise non en
fait on se fait tous briser un jour où
loge puis en même temps de cela la
plupart des choses qu'on vit
c'est la première fois qu'on les
expérimentés en tout cas à 22 ans
tout ce qui m'arrive je l'ait jamais y
auriez eu ce qui m'arrive que j'ai déjà
vécu avant tout on n'est jamais préparé
fact est constamment en apprentissage
c'est pour ça que je me dis je sais pas
quand ça continue tout le temps et tu
mets ça continue tout le temps intime et
on le met parents qui se séparent après
32 ans de mariage
comme c'est arrivé à personne ça leur
est jamais arrivé comme ça l'aurait
jamais arrivé oui sont ses parts il met
qu'inquiet ça arrive je serais jamais
arrivé il dépose souvent plusieurs fois
jamais arrivé de cette pêche par exemple
même s'il est prêt c'est tout les
chemins sont toutes des étapes sont
jamais arrivés mais tu es comme on
disait tantôt si les étapes du passé
nous définissent pas peut-être que ton
insouciance à peu se reconstruire
contact du petit fils à moi j'ai envie
de faire confiance pis j'ai pas envie de
miner notre relation avec quelques
occasions de fantômes qui servent ni à
elle ni à moité les deux bacs de chat
dehors et voilà ouais mais c'est un bon
là dedans mais je fais pas et on va être
là je vois tellement bien là reposoir
qu'on va pourra pas monétiser le podcast
à cause des gays ce que servier pour toi
attend le g7 puis qu'est ce que j'ai le
droit tel il s'en vient la saison 2
desigual trip toi tu le droit de donner
des thèmes on n'est pas encore été en
étant en étant de brainstorm pour ça
mais ça se prétend qu est-ce qu on peut
brestois mail pour aider les cabinets
commenter ce foot fois ci c'est ça la
gamme des tendances moins que vous
aimeriez qu'on démystifie le polyamour
scholes plus loin mais ça c'est sous
coke c'est trop intéressant projet les
passants tout ce qu'on a abordé gravité
aussi flou que l'expérimenté c'est un
problème pour tout bon été mais non mais
c'est sympa que une domination gémeaux
pour ckoi trip une belle saison qui s'en
vient
le drake ou spéciaux en tout cas moi
j'ai adoré mon expérience à c'est quoi
le truc j'ai adoré la capsule china il
faut que je t'avoue je n'ai pas tout
écouter mais j'ai adoré celle sur le
véganisme c'était vraiment serré en
personnel
est-ce que tu reviens à roue j'ai fait
un petit créneau c'est tout rouge
je me soucie rouge bel et bien et non je
reviens peu ça aurait été ma quatrième
année
qui dit comme je disais tantôt g20 deux
ans je sais que c'est comme mon excuse
pour me dédouaner tout mais il ya trop
de choses que je veux essayer de on
s'entend que de beaucoup de portes
ouvertes de vente où l iliade
independent moi je vois ça comme des
taupes
j'ai dit moi je suis je pour apprendre
sur le tas je vais apprendre sur tout
les jours
mais ouais je suis une année assez
remplie qui s'en vient le g1 douzième
livre en chantier en chantier mais tant
que je suis juste rendu à placer les
comble être comme n'ai pas trop eu lieu
chantier est ce que ce cercueil des
trucs à gauche à droite que tu écris ou
si ces sports accueille des chroniques
mais j'aime j'aime le font remarquer je
trouve que pour les gens qui lisent pas
beaucoup c'est le fun parce que c'est
super s'est évité de peu pour marquer
dans un gros récit c'est com - perrin
sait pas qu'on les sent d'ailleurs
est-ce que j'ai le truc à gauche à
droite que tu as fait non mais si son
premier recueil des chroniques pour le
même mois j'ai je me demande si je suis
une auteur publié jeudi non parce que
j'ai pas eu théâtre oui j'allais fait 2
à 0 mais trois entités publiques ou
drogue ce qu'ils avaient accepté ou
c'est aussi tout à fait heureux de
t'avoir reçues sur le site affaires
cubana way meirieu scavo et demain on
off cain fait beaucoup de podcasts au
sénat qui va résonner je pense pour moi
le micro mettrait vraiment le fameux
merci pour ce bel tant que garçon
josias bientôt yes